[Musique]
ambiance samedi après-midi dans les rues
de saint germain en laye pour l'acteur
11 du mouvement des gilet jaune près de
cent manifestants ont marché depuis
poissy une mobilisation pacifiste
encadrés par les forces de l'ordre
depuis plus de deux mois elle les
revendications n'ont pas changé
virez le président virer son
gouvernement changer de république
passer en sixième un rique ça c'est très
important
et puis bah de meilleurs salaires
meilleure justice pour tout le monde
surtout et pour ses gilet jaune pas
besoin d'organiser de grand débat
national pour se faire entendre
débat il est plus précieux ici entre les
gens finalement le débat avec son voisin
le débat en famille c'est ça qui est
important ce n'est pas le débat avec
macron qui fait ça plus pour les
européennes pour ces élections
européennes les gilet jaune seront
pourtant représenté avec une liste menée
par une grippe levavasseur liste qui ne
fait pas vraiment l'unanimité
je pense que ça a été fait beaucoup trop
tôt en fait il aurait dû attendre avant
de
de représenter les gilets jaunes si vous
prenez une liste aujourd'hui gilet jaune
elle va elle va dissoudre un le
mouvement et 2 ça va par rapport au
nombre de votes ça va donner de l' en
plus de pouvoir à mâcon ou autre ou un
autre parti politique
les manifestants doivent se consulter
cette semaine sur les réseaux sociaux
afin de savoir quelle suite donner à ce
mouvement
[Rires]